the job of the IMF is to find the
solutions which make everybody better
off sure how it can be done and then
push it argue try to convince the G20
China is both the world's second largest
economy
but it's also one of the poorest
crisis of contagion it's a crisis of
fear and you've got to stop that fear
I want to go straight to our government
to let our government know that they
have to work with the people
the IMF was viewed with genuine
repulsion you called in basically these
economic Thugs who imposed a dictat
[Music]
most people know the story of the Flight
of the butterfly in Africa leading to a
tornado in in Latin America and that's
very much what this is about one of the
big costs of interconnectivity is the
exposure to the volatility that markets
bring we need better multilateral
governments and if we don't get it our
children and our grandchildren are going
to pay the cost of that
[Music]
the IMF has to catch up with his time
institution has been founded UH 60 years
ago more than that and not surprising
that finally a lot of things has to be
done to adapt
at Bretton Woods New Hampshire delegates
from 44 Allied and Associate countries
arrived for the opening of the United
Nations monetary and financial
conference to be discussed our plans for
the stabilization of world currencies I
think it's hope and aspiration was
for the world to live in a more
cooperative and collaborative framework
for problems to be solved jointly and to
resist the temptation of countries
pursuing National agenda at the cost of
the global agenda they were really
trying to design a durable system which
would have a lot of stability built into
it and to do that they felt that they
needed to really constrain the freedom
of of flow of capital and and markets
today things are instantaneous and of
externally big
what happens in the U.S market or in
Europe can have devastating effects on
farmers in Africa or mining you know
miners or indigenous people in Latin
America
these interconnections do many good
things what we did not realize is uh
that you know when something is good
there might be a website to it and the
crisis has shown that the website could
be quite substantial so there wasn't
enough of an understanding of how
cascading failures in markets that
weren't very well understood could bring
the global economy to its name I hadn't
here my office focused showing that
situation is going to be very bad the
Davos 2008 World economic Forum meeting
in Switzerland has begun
one I want to Davos and I said which is
fair to say our view is that the
situation is going to be very bad and at
such a level and the global level that
we need a global stimulus what is clear
is that there will be a serious slowdown
and it needs serious response I think
the speech from stress Khan at Davos
did present a new face for the IMF
simply because you had somebody at the
very top saying these things
for planet Mars or so and
um
I remember it took long time for them to
accept
three months later in April 2008 we had
here in Washington the spring meeting
that we usually have every year and my
she said in my focus and that were all
too totally upset that the finest
Minister saying that you know you're
just joking well they didn't say joking
because it wasn't funny but they say we
know you our economy better than you do
it's not going to be that but of course
not going to be very good been
is that bad you're totally wrong and so
I remember being at the annual meeting
at the beginning of October of 2008 and
seeing people from different countries
come together and recognize that they
were sharing a very big problem by
Monday morning the market had clearly a
signal coming out of Washington that
Global policy makers get it
that they will do whatever it takes
to stop this paralysis
and that there was also recognition that
once the crisis is handled we're going
to have to fix the infrastructure good
evening from the G20 Summit here in East
London after coming together to try to
forge a Global Response the G20 in
London was really an unprecedented event
where you had 20 of the world's leaders
coming together and agreeing over a
trillion dollars of additional stimulus
to the world economy there is something
about crises that forced people to
overcome their differences and come
together to solve a collective problem
there was this very nice Coincidence of
the G20 existing as a structure and the
IMF being eager willing and ready to
help what has been done by central banks
by governments on the Mercury side for
the first one and the fiscal side for
the ladder has avoid a possible
catastrophe the London meeting became
the vehicle in a sense by which the
heads of States basically revitalized
the IMF as a multilateral institution
which could provide a collective
response it's very clear that the
emergence of the G20 now is a direct
recognition of the importance and the
weight for global economic recovery of
the growth of these emerging economies
so the Brazil's the China and India and
others that are really more or less
backing the whole recovery process now
the G20 Summit trebled the imf's
resources and that troubling included a
50 billion dollar allocation for
low-income countries the first time in
history really as far as I know that
facing the same problems such a large
amount of countries decide at the same
time to put in place the same kind of
policy and for this point of view it is
a very important point in the history of
multilateralism because it's really the
first multilateral action acts of this
magnitude the G20 has its problems the
IMF has its problems but more and more
people in an interconnected World
understand these institutions provide a
vehicle where we can at least hope for
progress
the IMF was viewed with genuine
repulsion and was a the bank of absolute
Last Resort when the state and
government had failed you called in
basically these economic Thugs who
imposed a dictat dialogue was not part
uh really of the way that the arm of
dealt with Africa then so most countries
including Tanzania in this case felt
it's a bit appeal
that they had to swallow when the
economic crisis happened
um
the IMF itself had to change radically
because the prescription had failed what
I guess we have learned as IMF are a lot
is that even sound economic advice that
does not factor in
political and social considerations
is not going to work the Tanzania
conference was called as a part of I
think a consultation process that the
IMF was having with different parts of
the world Africa came to that event with
a very clear set of asks
we had expected that this would be a
meeting that would allow the voice of
Africans to be heard if you had failed
regulation in the order of magnitude
that you've seen in a country like the
United States if that had been any
African country the IMF would have been
all over you like a ton of bricks I've
been to a number of these type of
meetings in my professional
career
that meeting was very candid we expected
IMF to change and at that meeting we
really had a very good conversation
exactly on these issues I think IMF has
come through with most of what they
promised they would do in order to
change introduce greater flexibility in
the way they dealt with really work in a
partnership framework
which I think for most countries it has
been clearly the the case now when I
talk to African Finance ministers in
that period their attitude to the IMF
was completely different they saw the
IMF as an organization that was there to
help them in a time of Crisis rather
than to beat them down
and the stigma that I think many Asian
countries felt after the Asian crisis
when they felt that in their time of
need
the IMF made it harder for them I think
that stigma shifted in this crisis where
many countries felt that in their time
of need the IMF was there to help let's
be frank after the memories in the Asia
of the Asian crisis the memories of the
Latin American crisis in South America
Latin American General
the fact that it was difficult for the
IMF to pretend to be really the globally
Global institution representing a
universal membership and so on I do
believe that it's
behind us
I don't believe that this wish that I
have of this dream of a coordinated
economy will appear overnight but I
think that we are making progress in
this direction good evening after 18
months Britain today finally dragged
itself out of recession a handful of
earnings reports helped to revive hopes
the economy is improving as the
financial crisis calmed down we have
seen countries pursue National agendas
that are inconsistent
with other countries National gender and
as a result the global economy is now
struggling
the recovery is losing momentum
and financial markets are getting
nervous again and it's clear to us that
the solution is not a national solution
it is a global solution so the job of
the IMF is to find the solutions which
make everybody better off sure how it
can be done and then push it argue try
to convince the G20 or governments in
general that that's a way to do it we
need an institution to be
where people worry
every day about this issue wait this is
their job that they wake up worrying
about it they go to sleep worrying about
it and they continuously implement it
because that cannot be done at the
national level the purpose of the
institution is to help the leadership of
sovereign states
communicate with each other and
sometimes tie their hands a bit and
bring along their citizens for the
greater long-run good of everyone I
think that's a worry that you won't see
big changes without you know without a
real change in the policy making and
thinking of a lot of the governments
that own the IMF the IMF they were part
of the problem
the great struggle now is to ensure that
they are part of some solution that must
be more proactive it must be literally
the listening Bank
[Applause]
[Music]
I think it's pretty reasonable to assume
that at some point someone perhaps in
the middle of the century China will be
15 to 20 of the world and I think that's
a very very positive story
the issue now is how does China keep
this up
it is both the world's second largest
economy
but it's also one of the poorest
[Music]
if we're talking about IMF role in the
world China is a very successful example
[Music]
China has grown at about nine and a half
percent on average every year for 30
years and that implies that the Chinese
economy doubles in size about every
eight years which is why China has gone
from being one of the poorest countries
in the world when it started its reforms
30 years ago in 1979 to the second
biggest economy in the world today
[Applause]
I joined the People's Bank of China in
early 1990s so we were at the early
stages of transition from a centrally
planned economy to a market-oriented one
so how to do that that was enormous
challenge
we found out that the fund had a pool of
experience
the IMF and China have had a very close
and positive engagement for many many
years we actually have staff posted in
China and we've had that for the last 20
years the advice that the IMF has given
China is based on what we see happening
in other countries that have faced
similar situations
China has done a lot of Reform
successfully and I think in this process
IMF played a very constructive positive
role
[Music]
probably the main benefit of this rapid
Chinese growth is that the poverty rate
in China has fallen dramatically
in the early 1980s the rate was about 53
percent of the population lived in
abject poverty today that rate is eight
percent now given the size of the
Chinese population 1.3 billion people
that implies that an estimated 400
million people have been lifted out of
poverty
foreign
thing about the Chinese model at the
moment is a very state-led it is and
it's been particularly true in its
response to the crisis
It produced a fiscal stimulus
of A Sort that the world has really seen
it also produced a financial and
monetary stimulus that was remarkable
we have supported the response because
we think that the government stimulus
was very helpful it came at the right
time and it helped to cushion the
economy from the worst of the downturn
[Music]
China saw that exports were collapsing
and the Chinese government needed to
step in and to support economic output
and they did that through spending on
roads and infrastructure and on health
which helped them achieve their target
growth rate
[Music]
many of our clients benefited from these
stimulus policies and we benefited from
them as
Well's performance has shown a stable
and persistent growth in recent years
the biggest challenge for China is how
do you reduce its uh dependency on
foreign demand for Chinese Goods as it
is Chinese demand is way too low uh
household consumption in China May well
be the lowest ever recorded for any
country
the Chinese authorities recognize very
well the need to rebalance growth away
from a heavy Reliance on exports and
more towards domestic demand
particularly household consumption it
will be important to further develop
financial markets and a stronger
currency would help the exchange rate is
an important part of a package of
reforms that will help to rebalance the
economy basically we focus on
encouraging consumption and encouraging
the development of a service industry if
you spend a lot of money on Social
Security on retirement program rural
medical program and so on so forth
you'll see that the result is the
domestic consumption retail sale and
also domestic demand increase one of the
reasons why Chinese consume so little is
because they're very worried about lack
of Pensions that they have the lack of
health insurance that they have they're
worried about the amount of money they
have to spend on their children's
education
foreign
when I was young I didn't have enough to
save up and the idea of saving didn't
occur to me I didn't even know what to
say for
[Music]
I lived through the planned economy
during my childhood and life was hard
then but there was little pressure as
all of us were in the same situation
that is to say the division between the
rich and the poor was very little
incoming equality in China has gone from
being very flat two or three decades ago
to being really rather than extreme it
was particularly striking given that
this is a country where three or four
decades ago where there was an almost no
inequality
I think China is a developing country
and continue to be a developing country
for a long time
we have to have a scientific view of
development and we try to make our
growth more sustainable and balanced
and it's very concerned that it can't
achieve an upper middle income country
status it's worried that its growth will
falter it won't be able to lift the rest
of its 100 million people who live in
poverty out of poverty it has all the
concerns that you would expect from a
developing country
[Music]
the efforts that the government has
taken over the last year or two to
broaden and deepen the pension system to
improve the public health system these
are very much steps in the right
direction and we've supported them
Allah very difficult things that need to
be done one of the most obvious ones is
to the whole situation with migrant
workers
[Music]
1009 when I came to Shenzhen I earned
900 Yuan as basic center now the basic
salary is 1100 but we need to pay 300 or
sometimes 240 for fruit so the race is
nothing
are there many companies are recruiting
many people are looking for jobs as well
the competition is fierce
food provided are not good either
especially the accommodation usually
they put several record bed in a tiny
room beds that are provided by some
factories are flea bags
first of all
as China is become more and more
urbanized the policy is that dealing
with Urban rural divide have to be in
such a way that integration of rural
population of area are equal so that
those population can better participate
in the city
China could become a sort of consumer
Market that became one of the driving
forces for the global economy but this
issue of Market workers and the way
they're prevented from really settling
cities is one of the main obstacles
that's holding that bank
Chinese consume way too little where
people are mistaken is in thinking that
consumption is a discrete problem that
can be solved independently of a major
reform of the growth model that means
improving equality on productivity
instead of relying on cheap labor on
Innovation instead of just exporting
lots of goods to the world economy and
all these things require a much more
defined and transparent set of formal
institutions to give investors and
households confidence to invest to
innovate to spend to consume
[Music]
I think the challenge that we are facing
one is China's GDP is getting larger and
larger and the constraint to us is
become more
binding especially the resources
constraint
the energy constraint
and also you see the environmental
constraint
the adjustment to other countries as a
result of Chinese growth will cause some
to fear China as a threat there's a
growing recognition of the spillovers of
Chinese growth for other countries the
value of the fund in the in this regard
is to provide a forum for countries to
discuss policy issues
I think that the fund has been one of
the key International platforms through
which the International Community gets
better understanding of China and also
through which China gets a better
understanding of the outside world
[Music]
it's a bonanza it could be short-lived
nobody knows quite how much oil is out
there
[Music]
we look at oil as a second opportunity
being given to this country
there is already quite a bit of pressure
on the government to make a big splash I
want to go straight to our government to
let our government know that they have
to work with the people
[Music]
well it was back in 2007 that news
reports showed that Ghana had made a
world-class oil Discovery the true scope
of the size of the field wasn't exactly
known but it was clear from that moment
on that Ghana was soon to join the ranks
of Africa's oil producers
once oil comes into production it's
likely that the incomes of Ghana will be
raised about 20 percent and the tax
revenues will be anywhere between five
to six percent of GDP and that is quite
substantial uh given the uh financing
needs that Ghana has right now
[Music]
2008 was not just the difficulty with
the global crisis we also have very very
serious difficulties investment of a
much more serious difficulty in terms of
the internal management of our own
domestic economy 2008 coincidentally was
an election year and in our part of the
world electioneering comes along with
what you call complete lack of physical
discipline
by the end of the year there's a record
budgetary deficit pushing towards 20 and
there was a record trade deficit also
pushing towards 20 percent so giving
those difficulties we had no option but
to resort to the fund I mean for support
So in terms of stability the fund then
came in
so the if has been quite important to
Ghana for a long time
that relationship has had its
difficulties and also some smooth paths
it sometimes also led to the adoption of
programs that were never very popular
but in the end there is no argument
about whether going to meet at the fund
or not
in package amounted to slightly over 1
billion United States dollars
and in terms of the technical assistance
the fund has been able to increase the
amount of technical assistance that it
has provided to Ghana
The imf's View was it came into Ghana
to ask the guidance what they wanted or
to ask the government what they wanted
it's far less conditional than the the
sort of funding Ghana had in the 1980s
the situation was very different what
the government of President Mills
inherited in 2009 was a troubled economy
but it was by no means an economy on its
back
given the broad experience that the fund
has had in in advising sub-Saharan
African and other countries and the
management of the oil wealth we think we
can bring best practice to Ghana's
benefit I should say that Ghana has been
actually quite eager to learn from
experiences of other countries
[Music]
dependence on raw materials or depends
on natural resources per se does not
bring about the transformation of
economies in spite of the huge goal
Reserve that we've had we've not been
able to attain the levels of economic
transformation that we we so much long
for
[Music]
there's no point in having oil if your
average Union can't have education let
us know when you have an oil if
ghanaians can't go to hospitals and get
good health care
there's no point in having oil if a
young mothers are going to be dying in
large numbers from uh trying to have
children
so the first challenge is how do we
transform the national economy so that
there's value addition and we can earn
more
to run the economy and that we can
improve the standard of living of
citizens improve their skills
build social capital education what I
have improved infrastructure
[Music]
so it'd be very important for the
government of Ghana to identify
Investments where they expect high risk
of return so that even after the expiry
of the oil production right this
investment will continue generating
higher returns going forwards
[Music]
if it's done right loyal revenues can
really see the non-oil economy
[Music]
I need to have a complete reorientation
in terms of our mindset and
understanding that much as we have
natural resources the greatest resource
that we need to want you to focus on is
a human resource for our people
[Music]
one of the debates in Ghana right now is
how can oregonians become involved in
the oil sector and it's often labeled
the local content debate
I started this project because I believe
that young people must be empowered so
that this new industry this new oil and
gas industry that is coming to us here
they will be employable
[Music]
I am a mechanical engineering by
profession but I need before I can get
access into the oil and gas induction I
need to be trained
drilling okay
if you Empower people
they become useful citizens if you leave
them they become a problem to everybody
in the society
we have a lot of Youth in our area and
we're going to pray to the whole nation
and then the government that we should
employ the youth in our area there
we are a developing country we are a
relatively poor country and people
cannot wait to move away from poverty
and underdevelopment so you cannot fault
anybody for being expectant
you're getting the same across all
regions the way to go about it is to
engage much more in educating in in
letting them know that uh we can have an
overnight transformation of the
condition of all our people it has to be
a gradual process
we've invested in in significant
Outreach in the last few months to to
explain some of these issues government
efforts in that regard we of course are
listening to the concerns of the public
oil is a non-reliable resource right we
don't know how long Ghana will be an oil
producer so it is important that the
non-oil sector is not ignored I think
one of the priorities for investments
from oil Revenue should be and
supporting small-scale agriculturals
[Music]
agric is the Mainstay of the economy
employs most people and most people rely
on that
for their livelihoods
and it contributes the largest portion
to GTP
agriculture in Ghana has moved from
fully subsidized agriculture through
partial subsidy to a point where farmers
had no subsidy at all
we need fertilizer we need money to till
the land first and then we need the
seedlings which we can Nest so that we
transplant and the money is the most
important because without money you can
purchase the fertilizer the chemicals
which you have to spray
so if I don't have access to credit
there's no way we can really adopt the
general technology we are trying to push
so I believe that access to credit is
there is really a key
if we want to have to to develop the
Ghanaian agriculture
in other countries where we've worked on
the oil issue we've seen that the
agricultural sector has has dried up and
certainly you want to be able to manage
your economy so that oil which produces
very few jobs is not affecting the
sectors of the economy that are actually
employing people and keeping people out
of poverty
normally when there's an oil boom the
tendency is maybe to even ignore the
software for this exercise
like the Google sector but we are
putting in place certain interventions
to make sure that this doesn't happen
they all may come but we still need to
protect our life without traditional way
of life
everywhere you go the Ghanaian will tell
you we want we want transparency we
don't want any corruption we don't want
the revenue or a revenue to be used I
mean according to the whims and Caprices
of people who are in government
[Music]
we've certainly worked with the
ghanaians in terms of improving public
financial management and giving an
opportunity to both Parliament and to a
civil society more generally to
understand the budget and to understand
exactly what resources are going where
I think the aim was for Ghana to be a
middle-income country by 2020.
it's technically doable but it's going
to require a really determined and
disciplined government to to deliver
that
if it is that we can do that we
anticipate that oil will become a
catalyst that can bring about the
transformation we are looking for and
maybe we then can become the kind of
positive example and that could Inspire
Africa
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
countries in Central and Eastern Europe
have been worse hit by the financial and
economic crisis than probably any other
region of the world and in that however
Poland has been an exception
Poland was the only country of the
opinion Union not to plunge into
recession
[Applause]
chance of becoming an economic
Powerhouse of Europe
nothing less than that
[Music]
solidarity had a lot to celebrate on its
ninth birthday today it complains of
transformed politics in Poland and now
it's heading the country's new
government the promise of 1989 was that
the end of the Cold War is the end of
the social antagonism I mean we really
thought after 1989 that there is one way
there's necessity There's One Direction
we and we have no time to discuss it
because we have to catch
up with the Western countries Poland has
been through a big crisis and it was
faced with how to move into the modern
world how to change the entire structure
of the economy to become competitive and
to become a a western capitalist economy
I think it's got to be said that to a
great many people the change of the
system was a great joy but equally it
surprised them too because suddenly it
turned out that people had full
responsibility for their own lives four
well educated people living in a big
city is young enough to fight on the
market it was great time but the problem
was that the big part of the society was
completely excluded and then frustrated
unemployment is expected to pass one
million this year warsaw's job office
has never been so busy almost no one was
listed as unemployed a year ago now
Poland has 400 000 people looking for
jobs
those people found it extremely
difficult to become re-employed many of
them really became not generalized so
they were
those who lost was it going to work well
I do remember documents inside the fund
which gave it a 50 chance of working but
the Polish policy makers were determined
to do it they had the courage to do it
and we didn't have the option then not
to support such a courageous bunch of
reformers what we are doing
is
to assist your government
in the design of its program and it is
our job in the IMF to put out its
disposal
our experience
and our knowledge of this kind of
problems
Not only was the Communist economy but
also didn't have a lot of skills
necessary to Simply run the market
economy so some technical assistance was
absolutely crucial
[Music]
for me it was very great time because if
somebody had a good idea and a little
bit manner that was a very big
possibility to make anything it was not
only for money it was very big Spirit
feelings that our products are finding
place in our customers
within Poland there's always been you
know people are very individualistic and
they don't like to be told to be told to
be ordered around and obviously a good
way of not being ordered around is To Be
Your Own Boss
so 20 years ago we have started this
film with my partner in a small garage
with two persons in this time we had
used only cash so the cash flow was very
Speedy we have possibility to buy new
things new machines it was very easy
getting rich that was the main idea
behind almost everything that happened
in Poland in terms of economics of
course getting rich and getting normal
so the initial success was due to the
entrepreneurship of poles but then the
big step forwards was due to the fact
that Poland started to attract a lot of
the investment
the market was developing there was a
growing abundance of goods we'd lived in
this Homespun poverty for so many years
and everybody was really enjoying all
that
and now all these things are made in
Poland only brands are foreign but the
product is ours
our growth was not very impressive first
years we had even negative growth but
after some period of time the economy
started growing faster and faster and
faster and in mid 90s the growth
achieved even seven percent good
in the country is represented at that EU
enlargement reception was Poland it's
the largest of the 10 countries joining
on Saturday but what does EU membership
mean for its people
Paul's wanted to work and live in a
normal wealthy country and they did
everything possible to achieve this and
they did achieve this
opinion it was for us a Destiny for a
long time we really wanted to be in this
club
[Music]
the transformation has been so fast and
so extensive by this point that most
people have become reconciled to this
process but there were losers certainly
foreign
it's inevitable when you move from
socialism to a market economy that
you're going to have an increase in
inequality but what we know on Poland is
a very good example is that those
countries which moved fast
to reform
I've seen the smallest increase
in inequality
[Music]
the collapse of Lehman Brothers set off
a wave of panic on Wall Street we
thought that the whole world has gone
crazy
we were looking at the stock markets in
in New York in London in Warsaw
and we saw things we could not
understand we became anxious and and we
started to observe and the first
reaction of the government I should say
was that we have to cut our expenditures
of course the financial crisis was also
not nice for us because we are exporters
especially for the East countries like
Russia ukrainia and so on obviously some
problems did appear
a bigger budget deficit a bigger public
debt but for the time being it seemed
the real economy in Poland did not
suffer and the financial sector the
banking sector did not suffer
probably Poland is the only one country
around the globe that has that limit to
GDP written to Constitution so this was
one of the key elements that the low
debt which in relation with very
responsible fiscal policy resulted in
solid fiscal position we were much more
prudent we really did not lose our minds
in the good years before the crisis
homes followed more stable policies than
its neighbors but we were concerned that
the there could be a lot of spillover
from these neighboring countries when
you're dealing with the crisis of this
kind it's a crisis of contagion it's a
crisis of fear and fear picks the
weakest off but then moves on to the
stronger ones and you've got to stop
that fear and the way to stop that fear
is by International solidarity
[Music]
Poland situation was actually quite a
bit stronger than the other countries
and that's why the IMF was very happy to
give Poland support under the flexible
credit line and Poland was an ideal
candidate for this it was a country with
strong policies and yet there was the
risk that there could be a spillover
from the crisis in in neighboring
countries
so this is very scary that sometimes
people make decisions without having
knowledge about the situation in
particular country
it was a perfect time
for the fund to come with new instrument
Poland was assessed as a strong and
economy with solid fundamentals which
also was very helpful and it it also
supported polish government in front of
investors and in front of the markets
nothing has changed as far as the facts
are concerned but the perception of
those facts has changed and here the fcl
was a clear signal that the fund
believed in Poland and in a way that it
also believed in the whole of the region
[Music]
the crisis offered us a very unique
opportunity we always thought that it
will take us 30 years maybe 40 years to
catch up with the brightest in European
union now because of their recession and
our positive stable growth the period it
will take us to catch up with them we'll
show it
one thing we have really learned from
the Polish experience is that if the
policy makers have the courage to take
action in a most difficult situation
they can achieve remarkable things
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]